Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Great jubilation. Down there, the people are creating an uproar. The torches come. It starts at seven o'clock. Endless. Till ten o'clock.
感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。想要获取每周独家播客番外、无广告收听、系列节目抢先听，并加入我们广受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。狂喜欢腾。在那下面，人们正在大肆喧闹。火把闪现。从七点钟开始。无休无止。直到十点钟。
At the Kaiserhof. Then the Reich Chancellery. Till after twelve o'clock. Unending. A million people on the move. The old man takes a salute at the march past. Hitler in the house next door. Awakening. Spontaneous explosion of the people. Indescribable. Always new masses. Hitler in raptures. His people cheering him.
在凯撒霍夫酒店。然后是帝国总理府。直到十二点过。没完没了。百万民众在游行。这位老人接受了行进队伍的敬礼。希特勒就在隔壁的房子里。觉醒。民众自发的爆发。无法形容。不断涌现新的群众。希特勒狂喜不已。他的人民在为他欢呼。
Wild, frenzied enthusiasm. Prepare the election campaign. The last will win it hands down that was joseph goebbels in his diary on the 30th of january 1933 celebrating adolf hitler becoming chancellor um and dominic sounding rather like alfred jingle in charles dickens pickwick papers they're very kind of staccato burst of prose yes i had that's not a comparison i'd thought of before no but, but you're right. But perhaps a little shard of light in what is otherwise going to be a very dark story, because with Hitler's elevation to the chancellorship, obviously he has his, well, he's kind of seized control of the levers of state, hasn't he? But he hasn't got hold of all of them. There's still, you know, he has a certain way still to go. So what would be your sense of how inevitable
狂野、疯狂的热情。筹备竞选活动。最后赢下这场选举的人将稳操胜券——这是约瑟夫·查尔斯·狄更斯《匹克威克外传》中的阿尔弗雷德·金格那样，那种非常短促的散文爆发，是的，我以前没有想过这种对比，不，但是，你是对的。但也许在一场本将非常黑暗的故事中透出了一丝微光，因为随着希特勒登上总理宝座，很显然他已经，嗯，他某种程度上已经掌控了国家机器的权柄，不是吗？但他并没有掌控所有的权力。还有，你知道，他还有一段路要走。那么，你觉得现在
the establishment of a totalitarian regime is now that Hitler has become Chancellor? Oh, that is an excellent question, Tom. I would say, given the alignment of forces in January 1933, so President Hindenburg is the top man. Hitler is the head of the government. He is in the cabinet with only two other Nazis. So Hermann Goering, who is running the Prussian Interior Ministry, Prussia, the biggest state in Germany, and he's normally under the Vice Chancellor, Franz von Papen,
随着希特勒成为总理，建立极权政权的必然性有多大？哦，这是个极好的问题，汤姆。我认为，鉴于1933年1月各力量的组合，兴登堡总统是最高人物。希特勒是政府首脑。内阁中只有另外两个纳粹分子。所以赫尔曼·戈林负责普鲁士内务部，普鲁士是德国最大的州，他通常归副总理弗朗茨·冯·帕彭管辖，
but he's basically running it himself. And the Ministry of the Interior for the whole of the Reich is run by Wilhelm Frick, who's a Nazi of very long standing. So basically, they have the police, right? They have the police. They have the Interior Ministry, the police. But they have nothing else. Well, they have all the momentum.
但他基本上是自己在大权独揽。整个帝国的内政部则由威廉·弗里克掌管，他是一个老资格的纳粹党人。所以基本上，他们掌控了警察，对吧？他们掌控了警察。他们有内政部、警察。但他们没有别的了。好吧，他们拥有所有的势头。
They have the streets. But they also have the tacit support, I think this is absolutely crucial, of the kind of conservative power brokers. So against that background, I think it's fair to say, especially as they're facing a communist party that has made great progress in recent years, well, as events prove, I think all the Nazis have to do really is reach out their hand and they can take what they want. Because Papen, Hindenburg, the other kind of conservative figures, I mean, they think they're using the Nazis,
他们掌控了街头。但他们也拥有——我认为这一点绝对至关重要——某种保守派权贵阶层的默许支持。所以在这种背景下，我认为可以公平地说，尤其是当他们面对一个近年来取得巨大进展的共产党时，正如事实证明的那样，我认为纳粹所需要做的真的只是伸出双手，他们就能拿走他们想要的一切。因为帕彭、兴登堡和其他一些保守派人物，我的意思是，他们以为自己在利用纳粹，
but there's never, as we will discover, there is never a point when the Nazis can go too far for them. I mean, this is the, as we talked about last time, this is the sort of chilling lesson for any democracy. You know, if you don't, there has to be a point
但正如我们将要发现的那样，纳粹永远不会有对他们而言过分的时候。我的意思是，正如我们上次所谈到的，这对任何民主制度来说都是一个令人不寒而栗的教训。你知道，如果你不这样做，必须有一个时间点
where you draw a very very very firm line and if you're not prepared to do that then your foes will push and push and push and suddenly you'll wake up and you'll realize there is no democracy left and this is exactly what happens so so that's the case with poppin and the army and more generally the parties on the right, that they don't really want to draw a line in the sand because they kind of approve of quite a lot of what the Nazis are actually doing. I mean, they maybe feel the Nazis are doing their dirty work for them. But what about the parties on the left, the communists and the social democrats? Because they're what, about a third of the electorate, half the electorate? I mean, they could precipitate a civil war. Could they have done that?
你必须划下一条非常、非常、非常坚定的底线，如果你没有准备好这样做，那么你的对手就会不断施压、不断逼近，然后突然之间你会醒来，意识到已经没有民主可言了，而这正是发生的事情。所以，这就是帕彭、军队以及更广泛的右翼政党的情况，他们并不真正想在沙滩上划一条线，因为他们某种程度上对纳粹实际在做的很多事情感到赞同。我的意思是，他们可能觉得纳粹在替他们干脏活。但左翼政党呢，共产党和社民党？因为他们占了什么，大约三分之一的选民，一半的选民？我的意思是，他们本可以引发一场内战。他们本能做到这一点吗？
A civil war that they think they would lose. I think that's the key thing, that if the army are on the side of the right, which they undoubtedly are, then how does a civil war benefit you? Yeah, I suppose. You know, you could conceivably launch a general strike, but a general strike in the middle of the Depression with so many millions of people unemployed, I mean, you can fill those posts. A really ruthless government will find strike breakers. So it's difficult to see. The SPD, the Social Democrats in particular, have let things go so far that they've actually run out of levers of power. But let's go back to the 30th of January itself, so that moment.
他们以为自己会输掉的一场内战。我认为这是关键所在，如果军队站在右翼一边，而他们毫无疑问是站在右翼一边的，那么内战对你有什么好处？是的，我想也是。你知道，你当然可以发动总罢工，但在大萧条中期，有那么多百万人失业的情况下，我的意思是，你可以填补这些职位。一个真正冷酷无情的政府会找到罢工破坏者。所以这很难看出。社民党，特别是社会民主党，把事情搞到了这种地步，以至于他们实际上已经失去了权力杠杆。但让我们回到1月30日本身，也就是那个时刻。
So we ended the last podcast with Hitler swearing an oath to the Constitution or whatever, promising Hindenburg that he'll respect him, Hindenburg kind of shaking hands with him. But this is not a transfer of power like anything else because that scene that you describe from Goebbels' diary, I mean, Goebbels organizes this torchlight parade on that evening in Berlin. I mean, the Nazis themselves claim
所以我们上一期播客在希特勒向宪法宣誓之类的场景中结束了，他向兴登堡保证他会尊重他，兴登堡跟他握了握手。但这并不是一次寻常的权力移交，因为你从戈贝尔日记中描述的那一场景，我的意思是，戈培尔在那天晚上的柏林组织了这场火把游行。我的意思是，纳粹自己声称
there are kind of half a million, a million people. That's rubbish. There are probably 20,000. Yeah, it's very kind of Trump statistics. Yeah, very Trump statistics, 40,000. But again, you see, Tom, there's a very symbolic moment there. Hindenburg comes to the windows of his apartment,
有大约五十万、一百万人。这纯属胡扯。可能只有两万人。是的，非常像特朗普式的数据。是的，非常特朗普式的数据，四万人。但话说回来，你看，汤姆，那里有一个非常具有象征意义的时刻。兴登堡来到他公寓的窗前，
which is at this point in the Reich Chancellery, to take the salute of the crowd. Hitler, of course, does so too, but the police, they train their searchlights especially so that people will see Hindenburg. They'll see that he's given his approval to this transfer of power. And all the talk is of this is a, I mean, this isn't just a normal government coming in. So Goering is on the radio and he says, anybody who remembers August 1914 will remember that this feels just like that. Right. And that led to disaster.
当时这间公寓在帝国总理府内，以此接受人群的敬礼。希特勒当然也这么做了，但警察特意调整了探照灯的方向，好让人们能看到兴登堡。他们会看到他认可了这次权力移交。所有的言论都在谈论这是一个，我的意思是，这不仅仅是一个普通政府的上台。所以戈林在广播里说，任何记起1914年8月的人都会记得，这感觉就像当年一样。对。而那导致了灾难。
I mean, it's quite an odd thing to say, isn't it? Yeah, but I think the argument is that this time we will win. It's that last time we embarked on a great national crusade and we were defeated and betrayed. We were stabbed in the back. That's the Nazi claim. This time they're embarking on another national crusade, but a crusade of national renovation, and there'll be nobody.
我的意思是，这话听起来挺奇怪的，不是吗？是的，但我认为他们的论点是这一次我们会赢。意思是上一次我们开启了一场伟大的国家十字军东征，结果我们失败并遭到背叛。我们背后挨了刀子。这就是纳粹的说法。这一次他们正在开启另一场国家十字军东征，但这是一场国家复兴的十字军东征，而且不会有任何人。
We'll make sure no one stabs us in the back again. And the thing about all that you know you talked about goebbels and his talents as a theatrical impresario and you also talked last time didn't you about horst vessel a lot of young people undoubtedly are swept up by this so richard evans in his books um on the coming of the third reich that we've quoted from fairly extensively in the last three episodes he has a very very he uses the um the memoirs of a woman called melita maskman now she was a a nazi propagandist but she was a teenager at this point she was 15 years old and and she later on remembering this decades later she said she wrote we want to die for the flag the torch bearers had sung. I was overcome
我们会确保没有人会在背后给我们捅刀子。关于你所说的这一切，你知道你谈到了戈培尔和他作为戏剧总监的天赋，你上一次也谈到了霍斯特·韦塞尔，对吧，许多年轻人毫无疑问都被卷入了其中。理查德·埃文斯在他关于第三帝国崛起的书中所写的——我们在前三集里相当广泛地引用过这些书——他引用了一位名叫梅利塔·马什曼的女性的回忆录，现在她是一位纳粹宣传员，但当时她还是个青少年，她只有15岁，几十年后她回忆起这段往事时说，她写道：我们想为国旗去死，举火把的人一直在唱歌。我被一种
with a burning desire to belong to these people for whom it was a matter of life and death. I wanted to escape from my childish, narrow life and to attach myself to something that was great and fundamental. And I think there's no doubt that when the Nazis take power at the end of January 33, that they do capture the imagination of a lot of actually quite idealistic young people who have maybe become desensitized to the violence and the horror. Or maybe are just dazzled by the torchlight displays and the flags and the swagger of it all, do you think?
强烈的渴望所淹没，渴望成为这些人中的一员，对他们来说，生死攸关。我想逃离我那稚嫩、狭隘的生活，去依附于某种伟大而根本的东西。我认为毫无疑问，当纳粹在33年1月底夺取权力时，他们确实抓住了许多实际上相当具有理想主义色彩的年轻人的想象力，这些年轻人可能对暴力和恐怖已经变得麻木了。或者可能只是被火把游行、旗帜以及这一切的傲慢自大给迷惑了，你觉得呢？
Yes, of course. Oh, absolutely. I mean, you definitely get that from her memoir.'s she's out there her parents take her out there is actually violence at the demonstration she writes of somebody being punched in front of her and yet the sense of excitement the sense of a fervor of that sense of a crusade i mean you know if you're a teenager that would we did a podcast some time ago tom about the white rose movement that sense of a crusade. I mean, you know, if you're a teenager, we did a podcast sometime ago, Tom, about the White Rose Movement,
是的，当然。哦，绝对是的。我的意思是，你绝对可以从她的回忆录中感受到这一点。她当时就在现场，她的父母带她去的。游行现场其实发生了暴力事件，她写到有人在她面前被打了一拳，然而那种兴奋感、那种狂热的感觉、那种十字军东征的感觉——我的意思是，如果你是个青少年，我们会——汤姆，我们前段时间做过一期关于白玫瑰运动的播客，那种十字军东征的感觉。我的意思是，如果你是个青少年，汤姆，我们前段时间做过一期关于白玫瑰运动的播客，
about the Scholls, Hans and Sophie Scholl. And they were very seduced by it, weren't they? They were seduced by it at first. You know, these very idealistic... Even though their father hated the Nazis. Yeah.
关于绍尔兄妹，汉斯和苏菲·绍尔。他们当时不是很受其诱惑吗？他们起初被它诱惑了。你知道，这些非常理想主义的……尽管他们的父亲讨厌纳粹。是的。
The Nazis were exciting. But I suppose to understand how they succeed, you have to, in a sense, kind of park that retrospective judgment and try and see it through the eyes of someone who doesn't know what's coming. And who might be naive, might be so young that they don't really have an understanding of politics. And just, I suppose, kind of grasp a sense of the dazzle of it all. They've been in the gutter.
纳粹当时让人觉得很兴奋。但我想，要理解他们是如何成功的，从某种意义上说，你必须抛开这种事后的判断，试着通过一个不知道接下来会发生什么的人的眼光去看待它。一个可能很天真，年轻到对政治根本没有真正理解的人。并且仅仅，我想，去抓住那种被这一切迷住的感觉。他们曾身处阴沟。
And now they're being lifted up to see the stars. I mean, it sounds so trite, but I mean, if they're young, like, like Melita Meshman, I mean, they,
而现在他们被抬高去仰望星空。我的意思是，这听起来太陈腐了，但如果他们很年轻，就像——就像梅利塔·梅什曼一样，我的意思是，他们
they would have no real understanding of politics. I mean, they would be completely seduced by, by, by what they're seeing. And so that's being laid on as, as a way of kind of winning support, but presumably the two urgent tasks that the Nazis face,
对政治不会有真正的理解。我的意思是，他们会被他们所看到的一切彻底迷惑。所以这一切都被安排好，作为一种赢得支持的方式，但可以推测的是，纳粹面临的两个紧迫任务是，
if they're going to consolidate this um this uh elevation of hitler to the chancellorship they need to square the army yep and they need to neutralize the left-wing parties yes would that was that those would be the two kind of prime i think absolutely yes they want to? They need the army on board for what they plan. So within days, I think four days or so, Hitler gives a speech to senior officers of the army. There is a new minister of defense who has been installed by the army's behest, basically, Wernher von Blomberg. He is much more sympathetic to the Nazis than Hindenburg or Papen, imagine.
如果他们要巩固这种——这种——希特勒晋升为总理的地位，他们需要搞定军队，是的，他们需要把左翼政党边缘化，是的，这会是那两个主要的——我想绝对是的。他们为了他们的计划需要军队的支持。所以在几天之内，我想大概四天左右，希特勒向军队高级军官发表了一演讲。根据军队的要求，基本上设立了一位新的国防部长，维尔纳·冯·勃洛姆堡。他比兴登堡或帕彭想象的要更加同情纳粹。
So, you know, that's a great win for Hitler, if you like, that is somebody who is basically, he's a military man, he wants to see Germany great again. So it's fine by him that the Nazis are in charge. But if he hadn't been sympathetic to the Nazis, then what? I don't think it's conceivable that anybody would have been in that position who wasn't vaguely sympathetic to the Nazis. I think all the conceivable leaders of the army at that point, or ministers of defense or whatever,
所以，你知道，对希特勒来说，这是一个巨大的胜利，如果你愿意这么说的话，这是一个基本上是军人的人，他希望看到德国再次伟大。所以纳粹掌权对他来说是完全可以接受的。但如果他当时不同情纳粹，那又会怎样呢？我认为不可能有人会处于那个位置而对纳粹没有丝毫同情。我认为当时军队的所有潜在领袖，或者国防部长之类的人，
because they think that the alternative is either endless political paralysis by these kind of parliamentary pygmies or communism. Hitler goes to talk to the senior officers in the army on the 3rd of February, 1933. And he says to them, listen, what I want to do is I want to bring back conscription. I want to build up Germany as a military machine again. I want to smash Marxism so that threat is gone forever. And I want to rip up the Treaty of Versailles, which has humiliated us. We weren't beaten in the First World War. We were stabbed in the back. Let's rip up Versailles and get our honour back and all this. And is he saying we're prepared to risk war with France and Britain?
因为他们认为唯一的选择要么是这些议会侏儒造成的无休止的政治瘫痪，要么就是共产主义。希特勒于1933年2月3日向军队高级军官发表了讲话。他对他们说：听着，我想做的是恢复征兵制。我想把德国重新建设成一个军事机器。我要粉碎马克思主义，让这种威胁永远消失。我想撕毁羞辱了我们的《凡尔赛条约》。我们在第一次世界大战中没有被击败。我们是被背后捅刀子的。让我们撕毁凡尔赛条约，找回我们的尊严，诸如此类。他是说我们准备冒与法英两国开战的风险吗？
Or we're willing to dismember Poland? He makes no bones about living space in the East, about Germany needs to expand. They go along with that, do they? Well, a lot of them think, great. I mean, don't forget, if you go back to our very first podcast, Tom, which was on this subject, which was, we started off talking about
还是我们愿意瓜分波兰？他毫不掩饰关于东部生存空间的看法，关于德国需要扩张。他们赞同这一点吗？好吧，很多人觉得，太棒了。别忘了，如果你回到我们的第一期播客，汤姆，那个关于这个主题的节目，我们最初讨论的是
all the intellectual currents of the 19th century. I mean, these men are products of their times as much as Hitler is. So a lot of them have read all this stuff. They've grown up amid talk of Lebensraum, pan-Germanism, Germany's national destiny, all this business. So they think to themselves, well, this is great. This is what I want to hear.
19世纪的所有思潮。我的意思是，这些人是他们时代的产物，希特勒也是。所以他们中的很多人都读过这些东西。他们在关于“生存空间”、大日耳曼主义、德国国家命运等各种言论中长大。所以他们心想，太棒了。这正是我想听到的。
Somebody who finally will put us back on the map, as it were. Sensible policies for a happier Germany. That is what they think. Everybody who's become chancellor in the last couple of episodes of this podcast has immediately called an election to try and get a majority Hitler is determined to do this he wants a final showdown with Marxism as he puts it that's what he wants the election to be about but why why does he want an election why doesn't he just rely on force because at this point he feels like he needs the impression of legality that I mean the Nazis they get their totalitarian regime through political i mean obviously there's a violence on the streets obviously there's loads of intimidation and horror
终于有人能把我们重新放回地图上了，可以说是这样。为了一个更幸福的德国采取明智的政策。这就是他们的想法。在过去几集的播客中，每一位成为总理的人都立即宣布举行大选，试图赢得多数席位。希特勒决心这么做，他想要与马克思主义进行最终的决对决，正如他所说的那样，这就是他想让大选成为的主题。但为什么——他为什么想要大选？他为什么不直接依靠武力？因为在这个时候，他觉得他需要一种合法性的表象——我的意思是，纳粹通过政治手段获得了他们的极权统治——当然，街头有暴力，当然，正如我们接下来将要看到的，有大量的恐吓和恐怖，
as we will come to but they are always using the apparatus of democracy to do it and what he wants is legislation that will enable him to do that so to amend the constitution to basically give him what's called an enabling act that will basically allow him to override constitutional freedoms and to rule by decree himself, not relying on President Hindenburg will do it, and he'll basically turn Hindenburg into a complete cipher, a waste of space. But he needs two-thirds majority in the Reichstag to get the Enabling Act through. So that's why he needs an election. That's the requirement to amend the constitution. Correct. So basically, Hindenburg had refused Hitler's predecessor, General von Schleicher, a dissolution of the Reichstag, which Kershaw and Evans and the other historians think, you know, if Nazism was to be averted at the last moment, that's what Hindenburg should have given Schleicher. But he gives it to Hitler.
但他们一直都在利用民主机器来做到这一点。他想要的是能让他这样做的立法：修改宪法，基本上给他一部所谓的《授权法》，这基本上允许他凌驾于宪法自由之上，通过法令自行统治，而不用依赖兴登堡总统来做这件事，他基本上会把兴登堡变成一个彻底的傀儡、一个无用之人。但他需要在国会中获得三分之二的多数票才能通过《授权法》。所以这就是他需要大选的原因。这是修改宪法的要求。没错。所以基本上，兴登堡拒绝了希特勒的前任——施莱谢尔将军解散国会的请求，而科沙、埃文斯和其他历史学家认为，如果在最后关头要避免纳粹主义，兴登堡本该给施莱谢尔这个权力。但他却把它给了希特勒。
We've had 20 elections. Let's have a 21st. Exactly. And Hitler says to his cronies, right, the theme of this is attack on Marxism. That's what he wants the watchword to be. A fight against Marxism will be relentless. And of course, by attacking Marxism, making it about Marxism, he's able to put himself on one side as the guardian of stability, and the social democrats and the communists on the other to lump them in together. So he's getting loads of money pouring into the nazi coffers for industrialists so this is where the marxist idea that hitler has been brought to power by industry
我们已经举行了20次选举。那就举行第21次吧。正是如此。希特勒对他的亲信说：好，这次的主题是攻击马克思主义。这就是他想让口号成为的内容。对马克思主义的打击将是无情的。当然，通过攻击马克思主义、将其归咎于马克思主义，他能够把自己放在稳定卫士的一边，而将社会民主党人和共产党人归为另一边，把他们混为一谈。因此，他获得了大量涌入纳粹金库的资金，这些资金来自实业家。这就是马克思主义关于希特勒是由工业资本扶植上台的观点的由来，
basically comes from yeah because up to this point a lot of big business people and industrialists are very suspicious of the nazis they'd rather do business with the kind of conservative bigwigs that they've known and gone to clubs with and horse races and cocktail parties and so on, or yogurt drinking parties, as you claimed last time. Yes. So there's an extraordinary moment actually on the 10th of February at the Berlin Sports Palace, which I thought would really appeal to you, Tom. Hitler launches his campaign with this great hymn to national unity and talks of a national resurrection.
基本上就是这么来的。是的，因为在此之前，许多大企业巨头和实业家对纳粹非常怀疑。他们宁愿与那种保守派权贵做生意，也就是他们认识的、一起去俱乐部、看赛马、参加鸡尾酒会的人，或者如你上次所说，去喝酸奶的聚会。是的。因此，实际上在2月10日的柏林体育宫发生了一个非同寻常的时刻，我想这一定会吸引你，汤姆。希特勒以这首对民族团结的伟大赞歌拉开了他的竞选序幕，并谈到了民族复兴。
And he has this extraordinary passage where he brands himself as this sort of Messiah, as this Christ-like figure. I cannot divest myself of my faith in my people. I cannot disassociate myself from the conviction that this nation will one day rise again. Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. The hour will come at last in which the millions who despise us will stand by us and with us will hail the new hard-won and painfully acquired German Reich we have created together, the new German kingdom of greatness and power and glory and justice. Amen. I mean, you were talking before about Horse Vessel, the attempt to kind of ape Christianity and its rituals and its language, its ceremony, its spectacle, that's clearly what he's up to here, isn't it, don't you think?
他有一段非常不同寻常的言论，把自己塑造成某种救世主、基督般的 figura（人物）。我无法抛弃我对人民的信仰。我无法将自己与这样的信念割裂开来：这个国家终有一天会再度崛起。啦啦啦啦啦。最终的时刻终将到来，那些蔑视我们的人将站在我们身旁，与我们一同欢呼我们共同创造的这个得之不易、饱经痛苦得来的新德意志帝国，这个充满伟大、力量、荣耀和正义的新德意志王国。阿门。我的意思是，你之前谈到过霍斯特·韦塞尔，试图模仿基督教及其仪式、语言、仪式感、奇观，这显然就是他在这里所做的事情，不是吗，你不觉得吗？
Definitely. And trying to seduce Christians, Protestants, Catholics to follow him. Absolutely. Yes. The difference, of course, is that this is accompanied by a terror campaign. So we said before that the sort of muscles of the state are in the hands of Goering and Frick, his cronies. The army are clearly not going to step in and do anything. And immediately, basically, the stormtroopers go mad on the streets.
绝对是的。并试图诱惑基督徒、新教徒、天主教徒跟随他。完全是的。当然，不同之处在于，这伴随着一场恐怖运动。所以我们之前说过，国家肌肉掌握在戈林和弗里克及其亲信手中。军队显然不会介入并做任何事情。几乎立刻，冲锋队就在街头疯狂起来。
They're attacking trade unionists, communists, left-wingers, and so on. Goering explicitly tells the Prussian police, stop your surveillance of Nazii paramilitaries and other police pro-nazi the police go along with it i mean this is the fascinating thing about this that you can trace these threads all the way back so in the 19th century the police were very conservative and they saw the social democrats as the enemies of you know the the kaiser instinctively they're going to prefer the Nazis to communists. Exactly. That's exactly it.
他们袭击工会成员、共产党人、左翼人士等等。戈林明确指示普鲁士警察：停止对纳粹准军事组织和其他支持纳粹的警察的监视。警察对此顺水推舟——我的意思是，关于这一点最迷人的地方在于，你可以把这些线索一直追溯下去——所以在19世纪，警察是非常保守的，他们把社会民主党人视为（你知道的）皇帝敌人的本能会让他们更倾向于纳粹而不是共产党。正是如此。完全是这样。
And in fact, in February, later in February, Goering sets up an auxiliary police force. He says the police need help in combating the street violence. Right. And so this is what made up of brown shirts. Exactly. Brown shirts, the SS. Yeah, absolutely. There's too much street violence, so the people will sort it out. Yeah. The guys who've been the people will sort it out. Yeah, the guys who've been starting it will sort it out.
事实上，在2月下旬，戈林建立了一支辅助警察部队。他说警察需要帮助来打击街头暴力。没错。所以这支部队是由冲锋队员组成的。完全正确。冲锋队，党卫军。是的，绝对的。街头暴力太多了，所以人民会自己解决的。是的，那些一直是煽动者的家伙们会来解决它。
Exactly. All the time, the Social Democrats do nothing. Their own meetings, their own rallies are being broken up. Nazi stormtroopers are actually now, they're not just beating up communists and Social Democrats, they're killing them. So there's a good example. The Social Democratic mayor of a place called Stassf is shot dead by a nazi and and nothing happens and all the time the communists
完全正确。与此同时，社会民主党人什么也没做。他们自己的会议、他们自己的集会正在被砸毁。纳粹冲锋队现在不仅在殴打共产党人和社会民主党人，他们甚至在杀害他们。这里有一个很好的例子。一个叫施塔斯富特的地方的社会民主党籍市长被一名纳粹分子开枪打死，而什么都没有发生。与此同时，共产党人，
they are there we know that they're paralyzed the nazis don't really know that the nazis are worried that at some point the communists will strike back. The communists will launch a revolution. The communists will pull off some kind of coup. Do they believe their own propaganda about the communists being a mortal threat? I think they do. Yes, absolutely. Yes, it would make sense that they'd be.
他们就在那里，我们知道他们已经瘫痪了。纳粹并不知道这一点，纳粹担心在某个时刻共产党人会发起反击。共产党人会发动革命。共产党人会策划某种政变。他们难道真的相信自己关于共产党人是致命威胁的宣传吗？我想他们是信的。是的，绝对信。这就说得通了，他们会……
I think loads of Nazis believe their own propaganda. Does Hitler believe his own propaganda? There must be some part of him that's, he's so cynical and opportunistic. I mean, he's opportunistic, but he's also committed. But there must be part of him that knows that they're inflating the propaganda but deep down i think all the nazis do think that the communists are dangerous and the jews and left-wingers generally are deeply deeply dangerous and then they get what appears to be the proof. So we should talk a little bit about a man called Marinus van der Lubbe, who is a Dutchman, not a German. He's a building worker.
我想大量的纳粹分子都相信他们自己的宣传。希特勒真的相信他自己的宣传吗？他的内心深处一定有某种部分是——他是如此的冷酷和机会主义。我的意思是，他是机会主义的，但也是坚定的。但他的内心深处一定有一部分知道他们在夸大宣传，但内心里我确实认为所有的纳粹分子都认为共产党人是危险的，犹太人和左翼人士总体而言是极其极其危险的。然后他们得到了似乎能证明这一点的证据。所以我们应该谈谈一个名叫马里纳斯·范德吕贝尔的人，他是个荷兰人，不是德国人。他是个建筑工人。
He's from Leiden in Holland. He's grown up in intense poverty. He has flirted with communism as a young man, but the communists were too disciplined for him. He's a bit of a wastrel. So he ends up as a kind of a narco-syndicalist. Kind of a little bit like Hitler then. Yeah. You know, he stays in DOS houses and men's hostels and stuff. He's a drifter. Drifting from political extremes. Exactly right. And he decides he's going to go off to the Soviet Union. You know, that's his utopia. He starts going east and he gets stuck in Poland, can't get any further. So he turns back west again. And in February 1933, it finds him in Berlin.
他来自荷兰莱顿。他在极度贫困中长大。年轻时他曾涉足共产主义，但共产党人的纪律对他来说太严苛了。他有点游手好闲。所以他最终成了一个无政府工团主义者。有点像希特勒那样。对。你知道，他住在收容所和男工宿舍之类的地方。他是个流浪汉。在政治极端主义之间漂泊。完全正确。他决定去苏联。你知道，那是他的乌托邦。他开始向东走，结果被困在波兰，再也走不动了。于是他又向西折返。到了1933年2月，他在柏林落脚。
And he's shocked by the scenes in Berlin. He thinks these fascists have taken power, but nobody's doing anything about it. And his heart bleeds for the plight of the unemployed. And he thinks a great action, a great gesture will rouse the unemployed against these terrible fascists. And he has always been a great believer in property damage. He had damaged property in his hometown of Leiden in the Netherlands. And he thinks arson is the way forward. So on the 25th of February, he tries to burn down a welfare office, then a town hall in Berlin, then an old royal palace. And all of these completely fail. He's intercepted, the fires are put out, it's an absolute shambles.
他对柏林的景象感到震惊。他认为这些法西斯分子夺取了政权，却没有人对此采取任何行动。他为失业者的困境感到心碎。他认为一个伟大的行动、一个伟大的姿态将会唤醒失业者去对抗这些可怕的法西斯分子。他一直深信破坏财产的作用。他曾在自己位于荷兰莱顿的家乡破坏过财产，他认为纵火才是康庄大道。所以在2月25日，他试图烧毁柏林的一个福利办公室，然后是一个市政厅，接着是一座旧皇宫。所有这些尝试全都彻底失败了。他被拦截下来，火被扑灭了，简直是一团糟。
Not even really reported in the papers. So two days later, Marinas van der Lubbe thinks, I'll go on better. He takes the last of his money that morning and he goes and buys matches and firelighters. Then he waits until darkness. And that night at nine o'clock, he gains entrance. He sneaks in to the Reichstag, the German federal parliament, this grand, late 19th century building. And he's got terrible eyesight. So by what that means, bizarrely, he's like the Marvel superhero Daredevil. Because he's got very bad eyesight, it means his other senses are very sharp.
报纸甚至都没有怎么报道这件事。所以两天后，马里纳斯·范德吕贝尔觉得，我要干一票大的。那天早上，他花光了身上最后的钱去买火柴和引火物。然后他一直等到天黑。那天晚上九点，他成功潜入。他偷偷溜进了国会大厦，也就是德国联邦议会这座宏伟的19世纪晚期建筑。他的视力很差。正因为如此，奇怪的是，他就像漫威超级英雄夜魔侠一样。因为他的视力非常糟糕，这意味着他的其他感官变得异常敏锐。
So he's able to move around the darkened Reichstag. He goes to the restaurants and tries to set the furniture on fire. No good. No joy. He's just a very bad arsonist, basically. And then he finds his way into the debating chamber. And the debating chamber has these long, heavy, richly decorated curtains. Very flammable.
所以他能够在黑暗的国会大厦里四处移动。他去了餐厅，试图点燃家具。没用。毫无进展。他基本上就是个非常糟糕的纵火犯。然后他找到了通往议会辩论大厅的路。辩论大厅里挂着长而厚重、装饰华丽的窗帘。极易燃。
Very flammable. He sets light to the curtains. Up go the curtains. Up go the wood panels. There's a dome of the Reichstag debating chamber, debating chamber is an absolute inferno. Now, extraordinarily, across the street, Hitler's pal that he had sheltered with after the Beer Hall Putsch. Oh, Putzi. Putzi Hanfstengel, who I described as a sort of socialite, right-wing, waste-of-space socialite. Indolent.
极易燃。他点燃了窗帘。窗帘着了火。木质护墙板也着了火。国会大厦辩论大厅的穹顶，辩论大厅彻底成了一片火海。说来也巧，就在街对面，希特勒在啤酒馆暴动后曾收留过他的那个朋友——哦，普齐。普齐·汉夫施坦格尔，我曾将他描述为某种社交名流、右翼、无所事事的社交名流。慵懒的。
Yeah. Indolent right-wing socialite.'s got flu or something he's got a kind of he's got man flu a very heavy cold so the rest of them are partying or doing something but he's not there he's and he's he's staying in goring's residence in an apartment at goring's official residence and the housekeeper wakes him up and says the reichstag is on fire and and he stares out of the window the reichstag is on fire um he telephones goebbels and says the reichstag is on fire goebbels thinks he's joking he says it's not it's not a joke it's really and the nazis pile down to the reichstag and they are stunned by what they see and delighted delighted? And they immediately see the opportunity. So the head of
对。慵懒的右翼社交名流。他得了流感什么的，他得了类似——他得了男士重感冒，非常严重的感冒，所以其他人都在开派对或做别的什么，但他不在，他——他住在戈林官邸的一个公寓里，在戈林官方官邸的一间公寓里，管家把他摇醒说国会大厦着火了，他瞪着窗外，国会大厦着火了——他打电话给戈培尔说国会大厦着火了，戈培尔以为他在开玩笑，他说这不是开玩笑，是真的，纳粹蜂拥前往国会大厦，他们被眼前的景象惊呆了——而且欣喜若狂？他们立刻看到了机会。所以
the Prussian political police, this man called Rudolf Diels, he wrote an account of this later on, which Richard Evans quotes in his book. It's an extraordinary scene. Hitler turned to the assembled company, says Diels. I now saw that his face was flaming red with excitement and from the heat that was gathering in the cupola. He shouted as if he wanted to burst in an unrestrained way that i'd not previously experienced with him there will be no mercy now anyone who stands in our way will be butchered the german people won't have any understanding for leniency every communist functionary will be shot where he's found the communist deputies must be hanged this very night everyone in league with the communists is to be arrested against the social democrats and the reists is to be arrested against the social democrats
普鲁士政治警察的负责人，这个名叫鲁道夫·迪尔斯的人，后来写了一份关于这件事的记录，理查德·埃文斯在他的书中引用了这份记录。这是一个非同寻常的场景。希特勒转向聚集在一起的人群，迪尔斯写道。我当时看到他的面孔因为兴奋和穹顶内积聚的热度而涨得通红。他大喊大叫，仿佛想要歇斯底里地爆发出来，这是我以前在他身上从未见过的：现在不会再有仁慈了，任何挡我们路的人都将被屠杀，德国人民不会对宽大处理有任何理解，每一个共产党官僚都要在被找到的地方就地枪决，共产党的议员今晚就得全部绞死，所有与共产党勾结的人都要被逮捕，针对社会民主党和——针对社会民主党
and the reichsbanner that's the social democrats paramilitary wing too there will be no more mercy and deals says the police guy says hold on a second i don't have this is a communist plot which it wasn't i think van der lubbe all we can tell is that he acted alone and And Hitler says, no, no, no. It's an ingenious, long-prepared thing. The criminals have worked out very nicely, but they're miscalculated. Haven't they, my comrades? These subhumans don't suspect at all how much the people is on our side. And that, of course, is the moment and the turning point in the story,
以及“国会旗团”——那也是社会民主党的准军事组织——将不再有任何仁慈。迪尔斯说，这个警察说：等一下，我认为这是一个共产主义阴谋——而这其实并不是，我认为范德吕贝尔我们能确定的只是他单独行动——希特勒说：不，不，不。这是一个精心策划、筹备已久的阴谋。罪犯们盘算得很好，但他们失算了。难道不是吗，我的同志们？这些亚人类根本没有怀疑人民有多站在我们这一边。当然，从某种意义上说，这正是故事的时刻和转折点，
in a way, or the catalyst, because Hitler will use the Reichstag fire to cement his control of the German state. So Dominic, just before we go to a break, is there any suggestion that this was a Nazi plot? Yes, and it's wrong. So another book by Richard Evans about conspiracy theories came out about two years ago, and this was one of them. Either that the communists did conspire to set the Reichstag on fire, or that the Nazis set it on fire themselves. And there's actually no real evidence for that at all. Hitler was always, I mean, a terrible man, obviously, but Hitler did have some diabolical political qualities, and opportunism was chief among them. He was a brilliantly ruthless opportunist.
或者说是催化剂，因为希特勒将利用国会大厦纵火案来巩固他对德国国家机器的控制。所以多米尼克，在我们进入中场休息之前，有没有任何迹象表明这其实是一个纳粹阴谋？是的，这种说法是错误的。理查德·埃文斯关于阴谋论的另一本书大约在两年前出版了，这就是其中之一。要么是共产党人确实密谋纵火焚烧国会大厦，要么是纳粹自己放火。实际上根本没有真正的证据支持这一点。希特勒一直是个——当然是个可怕的人，但希特勒确实有一些恶魔般的政治品质，而机会主义是其中最主要的。他是一个极其冷酷无情的机会主义者。
So this was his chance. This was a freakish occurrence that he seized on and turned into the pretext for everything that was to follow. But no, the Nazis didn't do it themselves. And Lubbe, the arsonist, he's captured by the Prussian police, but is he executed? What happens to him? He is executed, Tom. He was beheaded, guillotined. So not by a Prussian axe? Not by a Prussian axe. I think three days before his 25th birthday. So in January 1934.
所以这是他的机会。这是一个他抓住并将其转变为随之而来的一切借口的怪异事件。但不是的，纳粹并没有自己放火。而纵火犯吕贝尔，他被普鲁士警察逮捕了，但他被处决了吗？他怎么了？他被处决了，汤姆。他被斩首了，用了断头台。所以不是用普鲁士斧头？不是用普鲁士斧头。我想是在他25岁生日的三天前。也就是在1934年1月。
And he was later pardoned, would you believe, by the German government. But he had done it. Yeah, oddly, because he did do it. But I suppose they were saying the death sentence for arson seems very strong. Okay. All right. Well, I'm glad all that's been cleared up. We'll come back in a few minutes
而且你敢信，他后来得到了德国政府的特赦。但他确实放了火。是的，奇怪的是，因为他的确放了火。但我想他们当时是在说，因纵火而被判死刑似乎有点太重了。好吧。好吧，我很高兴这一切都澄清了。我们几分钟后回来
for the very final section of this terrifying story of the rise to power of the Nazis. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip,
继续收听这恐怖故事的最后一部分——纳粹的崛起。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八秀场八卦的固定去处，
and on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to the rest is history um dominic you have brought us to the brink
在我们的问答环节中，我们将拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、番外节目以及抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《The Rest Is History》。多米尼克，你把我们带到了1933年
of the irrevocable triumph of the nazis in 1933 the right stag has been burnt down hitler has seized it as an opportunity to absolutely consolidate his power so what steps does he take i think we can probably tie up the rest of the story reasonably swiftly, Tom. So within hours of the fire, the police are heading out across Berlin. They have lists that they've long maintained of communist deputies and communist supporters, and they arrest about 4,000 people within hours. So the question you were asking before the interval about what if the police hadn't gone along with hitler what if the army or whatever i mean that's a sign of how prepared they are
纳粹不可逆转的胜利边缘，国会大厦被烧毁，希特勒抓住这个机会绝对巩固了他的权力。那么他采取了哪些步骤呢？我想我们可以相当迅速地把故事的剩余部分收尾，汤姆。大火发生后的几个小时内，警察就在柏林各地行动起来。他们手里拿着早已整理好的共产党议员和共产党支持者的名单，在几小时内逮捕了大约四千人。所以在中场休息前你问的那个问题——如果警察没有顺从希特勒会怎样，如果军队或其他什么会怎样——这就是他们准备得有多充分的一个迹象，
to strike against the left yeah so they've so they've absolutely been squared and lined up exactly that they well it's not so much that they've been sort of squared and lined up it's that they they've been predisposed to this for decades. Yeah. You could argue for going back a generation or so. So the next morning, which is the 28th of February, Hitler's cabinet, which, as we've said, is not full of narcissists, largely conservatives
准备好对左翼动手了。是的，所以他们已经被搞定并排列整齐了。完全正确，他们——与其说是被“搞定”和排列整齐了，不如说他们几十年来对这一点就已经有这种倾向了。是的。你甚至可以说这种倾向可以追溯到上一代人左右。所以在第二天，也就是2月28日，希特勒的内阁——正如我们所说，其中并不全都是纳粹分子，大部分是保守派
and sort of authoritarians, but not national socialists. They approve what becomes known as the Reichstag Fire Decree, the decree for the protection of people and state. And this has two big clauses. The first is to suspend the Weimar constitutional freedoms. So freedom of the press, freedom of assembly, freedom of association, and allows the police to arrest you basically, without trial. So the suppression of the press, freedom of the press, I mean, that hitler's predecessor bruning had already of course yes brought in so he's this is exactly the point isn't it that most historians would make that the trouble is so many of these things have been anticipated by more by less malignant actors yeah going back to the very beginning of the weimar republic so the nazis can listen, we're not doing anything.
和某种专制主义者，但不是国家社会主义者——他们批准了后来被称为《国会大厦纵火令》的法案，即《保护人民和国家法令》。这其中有两大条款。第一条是暂停魏玛宪法规定的自由。因此，新闻自由、集会自由、结社自由都被暂停，并允许警察基本上在未经审判的情况下逮捕你。所以对新闻自由的压制——新闻自由，我的意思是，希特勒的前任布吕宁当然就已经——是的，已经引入了。所以这正是问题的关键所在，不是吗？大多数历史学家会指出，问题在于其中许多事情早就被更温和、或者说不那么恶毒的行动者所预料到了，
Just pushing it an open door here. Yeah, that Friedrich Ebert didn't do using emergency legislation and so on. But secondly, the second part of the decree, crucially, it says the government can intervene in the affairs of the German states and basically do what it wants, push them around. But it's not the president who has this power. It is the cabinet led by the chancellor. In other words, it's taking Hindenburg's emergency power
一直追溯到魏玛共和国的最开端。所以纳粹可以说：听着，我们什么也没做。我们只是顺水推舟而已。是的，弗里德里希·艾伯特当年使用紧急立法等手段时也没少干。但其次，该法令的第二部分，至关重要的是，它规定政府可以干预各联邦州的事务，基本上可以随心所欲，对它们颐指气使。但拥有这种权力的不是总统，而是由总理领导的内阁。换句话说，这是剥夺了兴登堡的紧急权力，
and effectively giving it to Hitler. And again, that is something that Papen had done, wasn't it, in July 1932 when he deposed the state government in Prussia? Yeah, exactly. Quite right, Tom. A dreadful precedent. Papen hesitated at that. And he was like,
并实际上把它交给了希特勒。而这同样也是帕彭在1932年7月罢免普鲁士州政府时做过的事，不是吗？是的，完全正确，汤姆。一个可怕的先例。帕彭当时对此还有所犹豫。他当时觉得，
taking the president's power away is kind of giving an awful lot of power to the chancellor. The president's pretty important. But basically, he has to go along with it. Goering is telling everybody, the communists, I have evidence that the communists have been planning this plot for years. We must act now, otherwise we'll be swept away
剥夺总统的权力有点像是把太多的权力交给了总理。总统其实挺重要的。但基本上，他不得不顺应这一潮流。戈林当时在对每个人说，共产党，我有证据表明共产党多年来一直在策划这场阴谋。我们必须现在采取行动，否则我们将在与马克思主义的这场末日冲突中被席卷而去。
in this apocalyptic conflict with Marxism. And Hindenburg, aged 187, now pretty doddery, he signs it, gives away his own power. And does he do that because he believes Goering, because he's gaga? It's hard to say. It's really hard to say. Some historians think that he was gaga. So there are claims, there's apocryphal claims that when he watched the Nazi torchlight rally, the night Hitler became chancellor, that Hindenburg started talking to General Ludendorff, who wasn't in the room, and indeed hadn't been in the room for years, and thought that they were back in the First World War again. And people are like old man's gone completely mad but other people say that's exaggerated hindenburg did know what was going on but he just didn't he just went along with it
而兴登堡，当时已经187岁了——现在相当糊涂了——他签署了这份法令，放弃了属于他自己的权力。他这么做是因为他相信戈林，还是因为他脑子糊涂了？这很难说。真的很难说。一些历史学家认为他当时已经老年痴呆了。所以有人声称——有未经证实的传言说——当他在希特勒成为总理的那天晚上观看纳粹火把游行时，兴登堡开始跟鲁登道夫将军说话，而鲁登道夫当时根本不在房间里，事实上已经多年不在房间里了，他以为他们又回到了第一次世界大战。人们觉得这老头子彻底疯了，但也有人说这被夸大了，兴登堡其实知道发生了什么，但他只是顺其自然罢了。
you know he thought it was fine so this unleashes now the stormtroopers and co have you know they have carte blanche they unleash absolute terror against the communists and against the social democrats. They've been, stormtroopers, their own accounts that they've written, they say, you know, we had been waiting for this for years to fight back against the kind of Bolshevik hordes and now finally we could do it and no one would stop us. I mean, they believe they're cleansing Germany. And the election is still going ahead. Yes. Oh, yes. So it's the absolute refinement of this kind of ballot box
你知道的 他觉得这没问题 所以这就释放了风暴突击队及其他人 你知道 他们拥有全权委托 他们对共产党人和社会民主党人展开了绝对的恐怖统治 冲锋队 他们自己写过的一些记录说 你知道 我们多年来一直在等待这一刻 来反击布尔什维克的那种群氓 而现在终于可以做到这一点 并且没有人会阻止我们 我的意思是 他们相信他们正在净化德国 而选举仍在继续 是的 哦 是的 所以这绝对是这种选票箱
and street fighting strategy. It is, absolutely. It's terrifying, actually, in this kind of cold-blooded, I don't want to say brilliance, but it's effectiveness, I suppose. So they're arresting communists all the time, banning communist meetings. It's basically impossible to be a communist from this point onwards, even though the party is not officially banned until after the election. But the election goes ahead on the 5th of March. There are flags everywhere, swastikas everywhere, there are SS and
和街头斗争策略的完美结合 确实如此 绝对是 实际上这是可怕的 带着这种冷血的 我不想说是精彩 但我想可以说是有效性 所以他们一直在逮捕共产党人 取缔共产党员的会议 从这个时间点开始 成为一名共产党人基本上是不可能的 尽管直到选举之后该党才被正式取缔 但选举在3月5日照常举行 到处都是旗帜 到处都是纳粹标志 到处都是党卫军和
SA men everywhere. everywhere and actually even against that backdrop hitler doesn't do quite as well as you might expect so the nazis get 44 percent of the vote when you add that to their nationalist partners that's 52 percent of the vote but not the two-thirds required for the to amend the constitution no so what so we'll see how they get the enabling act in a second because that is, again, I said about cold-blooded, ingenious effectiveness. You'll see how they do that. First of all, they go for the takeover of the states.
冲锋队员 到处都是 事实上 即使在这种背景下 希特勒的表现也没有你想象的那么好 所以纳粹党获得了百分之44的选票 如果把这加上他们的民族主义盟友的选票 那就是百分之52的选票 但没有达到修改宪法所需的三分之二 没有 所以怎么样 所以我们等一下就会看到他们是如何通过《授权法》的 因为这又回到了我刚才说的冷血而巧妙的有效性 你会看到他们是怎么做到的 首先 他们着手接管各州
So again, building, as you said, on Papen's takeover of Prussia. So in the next few weeks, they raise the Nazi flag outside town halls, city halls, all over Germany. State governments are forced to resign or intimidated or put under house arrest. And the Reich Interior Minister, who's Wilhelm Frick, who's a Nazi, he installs special commissions to dismiss police chiefs and put in Nazi police chiefs and so on.
所以正如你所说 这再次建立在巴本接管普鲁士的基础之上 所以在接下来的几周里 他们在德国各地的市政厅、市政府大楼外升起纳粹旗帜 州政府被迫辞职 或受到恐慌或被软禁 而内政帝国部长威廉·弗里克 也是一名纳粹分子 他设立了特别委员会来解散警察局长 并安插纳粹警察局长等等
So the Nazis are basically a crushing local government. And by now, lots of social democrats are fleeing the country because they can see what's happening. So you have this surge of arrests. This is when Willy Brandt pleases. Exactly. People of that kind, organizers, party activists, party deputies, and so on. The far-sighted ones are already kind of getting out of Germany. And what about Brüning and people like that? Some of those are leaving. Some of them wait another year or so to the light of the long knives or so before they leave.
所以纳粹基本上在摧毁地方政府 到那时 许多社会民主党人正在逃离这个国家 因为他们能看出正在发生什么 所以你看到了这波逮捕浪潮 这就是威利·勃兰特离开的时候 没错 诸如此类的人、组织者、党内积极分子、党代表等等 有远见的人已经在某种程度上离开德国了 那么勃宁和这样的人呢 其中一些人正在离开 他们中的一些人再等一年左右 到长刀之夜左右才离开
Because, of course, it's that classic thing, isn't it, Tom, that people confront in all similar situations. Do you hold on? Do you hope things will improve? Do you close your eyes and hope to keep your head down? Or do you run? Because if you run, of course, you destroy your life. You leave your old life behind. It's a terrible dilemma to be in.
因为，当然，这是那种经典的现象，不是吗，汤姆，人们在所有类似情况下都要面对的。你会坚持下去吗？你希望事情会好转吗？你会闭上眼睛，希望能保持低调吗？还是你逃跑？因为如果你逃跑，当然，你就毁了你的生活。你把过去的生活抛在脑后。这真是一个可怕的两难境地。
But tens of thousands of people are arrested in Prussia, tens of thousands in Bavaria. course, you destroy your life. You leave your old life behind. It's a terrible dilemma to be in. But tens of thousands of people are arrested in Prussia, tens of thousands in Bavaria. In Bavaria, there is a very ominous development. So the Bavarian administration is now full of Hitler's old cronies, the people he knew back in Munich, people like Ernst Röhm from the SA, people like Hans Frank, Himmler, the new police president. And it's Himmler who tells the press on the 20th of March, they've opened a new camp for political prisoners, for dangerous communists and subversives at a place called Dachau. And it's not a death camp. Dachau is never a death camp. It is a concentration camp. But it's a concentration camp where people are being beaten to death and tortured and so on.
但成千上万的人在普鲁士被捕，成千上万的人在巴伐利亚被捕。当然，你就毁了你的生活。你把过去的生活抛在脑后。这真是一个可怕的两难境地。但成千上万的人在普鲁士被捕，成千上万的人在巴伐利亚被捕。在巴伐利亚，有一个非常不祥的发展。因此，巴伐利亚行政部门现在充满了希特勒的老密友，他在慕尼黑时认识的人，比如来自冲锋队的恩斯特·罗姆，比如汉斯·弗兰克，新任警察局长希姆莱。正是希姆莱在3月20日对媒体说，他们在达豪这个地方为政治犯、危险的共产党人和颠覆分子开辟了一个新集中营。这不是一个死亡集中营。达豪从来都不是一个死亡集中营。这是一个集中营。但这是一个人们被活活打死、折磨等等的集中营。
So there is absolutely, you know, the Nazis don't want to keep this entirely secret. They want to frighten you. They want to intimidate you. I mean, that's how it works. And what about Jews? Well, we'll come to Jews in just a second. Of course, during all this period, there have been increasingly ferocious and unbridled attacks on synagogues, on Jewish businesses, on Jewish shops and so on, Jews being attacked in the street. And whereas perhaps the police would have stepped in before, depending on the individual policeman or depending where you are, now it's very unlikely.
所以绝对有，你知道，纳粹并不想完全保密。他们想吓唬你。他们想恐吓你。我的意思是，这就是它的运作方式。犹太人呢？嗯，我们马上就会谈到犹太人。当然，在这整个时期，对犹太会堂、犹太人企业、犹太人商店等的袭击变得越来越凶猛和肆无忌惮，犹太人在街头遭到袭击。而以前警察可能会进行干预，这取决于单个警察或你所在的地方，现在这非常不可能了。
You know, you are being subjected to this campaign of horrendous bullying, violence, harassment, and possibly worse. So now Hitler begins to move towards the final step, the Enabling Act, that will allow him to rule as a dictator. It's preceded by one of these ceremonies, these spectacles that seems to capture everything that you and I have talked about in the last three and a half podcasts. It's called the Day of Potsdam Ceremony on the 21st of March. It's the opening of the new Reichstag, which is going to open as an opera house in Berlin. And it's held at the garrison church
你知道，你正遭受着这种可怕的霸凌、暴力、骚扰甚至更糟的运动。因此，现在希特勒开始走向最后一步，即《授权法》，这将使他能够作为独裁者统治。在此之前，有这样一种仪式、这种奇观，似乎概括了你和我过去三个半播客中讨论过的一切。这就是3月21日的波茨坦日仪式。这是新国会的开幕式，它将在柏林的一座歌剧院开幕。它在驻军教堂举行
that was the heart of the old Prussian monarchy. This kind of sacral space, Tom. A sacral space, yeah. And Hindenburg is there dressed in his full, you know, you said in the previous podcast, when he takes a bath, he wears his peaked helmet. He is there dressed in the uniform of a Prussian marshal. And he is standing beside, he salutes the empty throne of the Kaiser. Like the ghost of Bismarck.
那是老普鲁士君主制的中心。这种神圣的空间，汤姆。一个神圣的空间，是的。兴登堡也在场，穿着他完整的，你知道的，正如你在前一个播客中说的那样，当他洗澡时，他戴着尖顶头盔。他穿着普鲁士元帅的制服出席。他站在旁边，向德皇的空王位敬礼。就像俾斯麦的幽灵。
Yeah. He's like the ghost of Bismarck and kaiser's ghost is kind of there on the throne so this is a nod back to the imperial traditions and hitler is there basically in a sort of frock coat in a suit in a you know well because he can't he can't go as a corporal can he that but of course him there in his suit he represents the present and modernity in the future and hindenburg represents the past. And they shake hands. They lay wreaths together at the tombs of the Prussian kings. So for all the conservatives, for people who aren't Nazis but are on the right- It's very reassuring.
是的。他就像俾斯麦的幽灵，而德皇的幽灵某种程度上就在王位上，所以这是对帝国传统的致敬，而希特勒基本上穿着常礼服、西装，你知道的，因为他不能，他不能作为一个下士去，对吧？但是当然，他穿着西装，他代表了现在、现代性和未来，而兴登堡代表了过去。他们握手了。他们在普鲁士国王的陵墓前一起献上花圈。所以对于所有的保守派来说，对于那些不是纳粹但属于右翼的人来说—— 这是一个非常令人安心的时刻。
Very reassuring moment. This is in the tradition that goes back to the Kaiser and the war of 1870, 71, and all that stuff. Two days later, at the Opera House, when the Reichstag opens, Hitler is back in his brown shirt uniform. The place is packed with stormtroopers. The communist deputies are all gone. So now the Nazis don't need so many people to get their two-thirds majority. Because the communists are now elite.
非常安心的时刻。这符合可以追溯到德皇以及1870、1871年战争等等的传统。两天后，在歌剧院，当国会开幕时，希特勒又穿回了他的棕色衬衫制服。这个地方挤满了冲锋队员。共产党代表都已经走了。所以现在纳粹不需要那么多人来获得他们的三分之二多数。因为共产党人现在是精英。
Their seats don't count? They've been banned? Exactly so. Exactly so. Okay. So Hitler gives this – he'd given a moderate speech in front of Hindenburg two days earlier. Now he gives a very dark speech. He says, if you don't give me this enabling act, there will be civil war and I won't answer for the consequences.
他们的席位不算数了？他们被禁止了吗？确实如此。确实如此。好的。所以希特勒发表了这个——两天前他在兴登堡面前发表了一场温和的演讲。现在他发表了一场非常黑暗的演讲。他说，如果不给我这个授权法，就会发生内战，我对后果概不负责。
And actually, there is one very moving moment. The leader of the Social Democrats, Otto Wels, who's had numerous threats against his life. He dares to stand up and defend the Weimar Republic. He says our freedom and life can be taken from us, but not our honour. He's got a cyanide capsule with him because he knows what could await him. And as he's speaking, his voice is trembling, breaking with emotion. He says, in this historic hour, we German social Democrats profess our allegiance to the principles of humanity and justice, freedom and socialism. We greet the persecuted and the hard pressed. Their steadfastness and loyalty deserve admiration. The courage of their convictions, their unbroken confidence vouch for a brighter future.
事实上，有一个非常感人的时刻。社会民主党领袖奥托·韦尔斯，他的生命曾多次受到威胁。他敢于站出来捍卫魏玛共和国。他说，我们的自由和生命可以被夺走，但我们的荣誉不能。他随身带着一粒氰化物胶囊，因为他知道等待他的是什么。当他说话时，他的声音在颤抖，带着激动而哽咽。他说，在这个历史性的时刻，我们德国社会民主党人宣誓效忠于人道与公正、自由与社会主义的原则。我们向受迫害和压迫的人致意。他们的坚定和忠诚值得钦佩。他们坚定的信念，他们不屈的信心，预示着一个更光明的未来。
And when he ends, the Nazis are jeering him and booing him and hurling abuse and threats and all this stuff. And then they vote. 444 people vote for Hitler's Enabling Act. That's not just the Nazis. It's the liberal parties. It's the conservative parties. It's the Catholic Center Party.
当他结束时，纳粹们在嘲笑他、嘘他、大声辱骂和威胁等等。然后他们投票。444人投票赞成希特勒的《授权法》。这不仅仅是纳粹。还有自由党。还有保守党。还有天主教中央党。
They all fall into line, only the Social Democrats, 94 of of them dare to vote against it but of course at that point the whole thing is lost and so vels he goes into exile doesn't he he does so he does indeed ends up in czechoslovakia i think hitler can rule by decree from this point onwards he doesn't even need hindenburg anymore hindenburg's just a glorified rubber stamp he doesn't even need the rice tag and. And from that point onwards, everything falls into place. They take over the trade unions. They ban the Social Democratic Party. The Catholic Centre Party dissolves itself. The first book burnings happen in May.
他们都顺从了，只有社会民主党，其中94人敢于投票反对它，但当然，到那个时候，一切都失去了，所以韦尔斯流亡了，不是吗？他的确如此，最终去了捷克斯洛伐克，我想从这个时间点开始，希特勒可以通过法令统治，他甚至不再需要兴登堡了，兴登堡只是一个被美化的橡皮图章，他甚至不需要国会了。从那个时间点开始，一切都水到渠成了。他们接管了工会。他们取缔了社会民主党。天主教中央党自行解散。五月份发生了第一次烧书事件。
I mean, we've talked a lot about youth and young people in these episodes. Those book burnings, like the attacks on universities and academic freedom, they are driven by students themselves. It is students who disrupt their own lectures, who inform on their own professors. It is students who organize the famous book burnings of the 10th of May held in 19 different universities to students themselves who compile the lists of the books to be cancelled, throw them onto the bonfire. They're the most, you know... Burning idealism of youth.
我的意思是，我们在这些节目中谈了很多关于青年和年轻人的问题。那些烧书事件，就像对大学和学术自由的攻击一样，是由学生自己推动的。正是学生们扰乱了自己的讲座，向自己的教授告密。正是学生们组织了5月10日在19所不同的大学举行的著名的烧书活动，正是学生们自己编制了要取缔的书籍名单，把它们扔进篝火中。他们是最，你知道的…… 青年的炽热理想主义。
Yeah, exactly, Tom. People dissolve their clubs. They dissolve... If you're in a stamp collecting club, it either becomes a Nazi stamp collecting club or you scrap it. Why do people do it?
是的，绝对是，汤姆。人们解散了他们的俱乐部。他们解散了……如果你在一个集邮俱乐部里，它要么变成一个纳粹集邮俱乐部，要么你把它取消。人们为什么要这么做？
Because this is what totalitarianism is all about. There can be nothing that is exclusive of the state. There can be none of Edmund Burke's little platoons of voluntary people just, you know, who are united by something external to the Nazi crusade. Basically, the only institution that does retain a kind of normal independence is the Catholic Church, isn't it? Because the Concordat is signed in this year as well. But they make an accommodation, Tom.
因为这就是极权主义的全部意义所在。没有什么可以独立于国家之外。埃德蒙·伯克所说的那些由自愿人群组成的小团体，你知道的，被某种独立于纳粹十字军东征之外的事物联合在一起的小团体，将不复存在。基本上，唯一保留了某种正常独立性的机构是天主教教会，不是吗？因为今年也签署了《协定》。但他们做出了妥协，汤姆。
They make an accommodation, and that's why the Catholic Central Party dissolves itself. Yeah, and the Catholic Central Party, I believe, advised its members. It said, approach your Nazi colleagues and offer your services to them. And boycotts of Jewish shops. So maybe the moment to end, we did two podcasts at the beginning of the year about Auschwitz, but maybe the moment to end our narrative is the 1st of April, 1933. That is the first boycott of Jewish shops and businesses. When you have stormtroopers, Nazi Party activists standing outside Jewish shops and businesses, when you have stormtroopers, Nazi party activists standing
他们做出了妥协，这就是为什么天主教中央党自行解散的原因。是的，天主教中央党，我相信，建议其成员。它说，去找你的纳粹同事，向他们提供你的服务。以及抵制犹太商店。所以也许结束的时刻，我们在今年年初制作了两个关于奥斯威辛的播客，但也许结束我们叙事的时刻是1933年4月1日。那是对犹太商店和企业的第一次抵制。当你有冲锋队员、纳粹党积极分子站在犹太商店和企业外面时，当你有冲锋队员、纳粹党积极分子站在
outside Jewish shops and businesses telling people, you don't come in here, or putting up signs. And that is, of course, the first, well, it's not the first warning by any means, but it's the most shocking warning yet of what is to follow. And there are no constitutional or practical breaks on what Hitler can do now? No. He can do what he wants. And he does.
犹太商店和企业外面告诉人们，你不能进来，或者竖起标语。这当然是第一次，嗯，这绝不是第一次警告，但这是对接下来将要发生的事情最令人震惊的警告。现在对于希特勒能做的事情，没有任何宪法或实际的制约了吗？没有。他可以做他想做的事。而他也确实这样做了。
Well, what a dark, dark story. What a dark story. So I guess there are various questions, aren't there, that come out of this. So one of them is what if? Was there an alternative? Could the Weimar republic have endured and become a success i mean i think you've answered that yeah i was going to say it seems i mean sure
好吧，多么黑暗，多么黑暗的故事。多么黑暗的故事。所以我想有各种各样的问题，不是吗，由此产生。其中之一就是如果呢？有没有替代方案？魏玛共和国本可以持久并取得成功吗，我的意思是我想你已经回答了，是的，我本想说它看起来，当然
it's hard to see how it could have not whether the weimar republic could have been a success but whether hitler could have been stopped which is slightly different and again and again there were moments where they could have been stopped yeah Yeah. Had firm lines been drawn in the sand. And to reiterate, now those lines probably would be drawn because we have this precisely this lesson in front of us. This is the paradigmatic moral political exemplar that haunts everybody. Yeah. To the degree that people are willing to see Hitler where
很难看出它怎么可能不成功，不是魏玛共和国能否成功，而是希特勒是否本可以被阻止，这略有不同。一次又一次，曾经有过可以阻止他们的时刻，是的。如果划下了坚定的底线。重申一下，现在这些底线可能会被划下，因为我们面前就有这个确切的教训。这是困扰每个人的范例般的道德政治榜样。是的。以至于人们愿意在
clearly Hitler doesn't exist, I would say. But equally, people are very understandably terrified of being the people who don't draw the line in the sand. Yeah, we're conscious of the threats. I think we're conscious of two things, aren't we, when we contemplate this story. So one is that democracy always has the potential to destroy itself because by nature, the tolerance and pluralism of democracy means you have to tolerate, or we tend to tolerate, the intolerant, yeah, anti-democratic parties, parties who would actually like to scrap the entire, you know,
显然没有希特勒的地方看到希特勒，我想是这样的。但同样，人们非常可以理解地害怕成为那个没有划下底线的人。是的，我们意识到了威胁。我想当我们思考这个故事时，我们意识到了两件事，不是吗？首先是民主总是具有自我毁灭的潜在可能，因为就其本质而言，民主的宽容和多元主义意味着你必须宽容，或者我们倾向于宽容那些不宽容的人，是的，反民主的党派，那些实际上想要废除整个，你知道的，
it's like competitors in the sport who actually want to destroy the sport, as it were. But the other thing is um i suppose it's what this story tells us about humanity and human nature even in the most sophisticated modern literate self-consciously civilized society that the people who go along with this a lot of the people who facilitate it are judges police chiefs intellectuals i mean university students people from you know successful they're not all that the stereotype is to say oh these are people who are angry who are left behind who are resentful and of course they are but a lot of them are very well adjusted
就像体育运动中的竞争对手，他们实际上想要摧毁这项运动一样。但另一件事是，嗯，我想这就是这个故事告诉我们关于人性和人类天性的事情，即使在最精致、最现代、最有文化、有自觉文明的社会里，那些顺从这一点的人，很多促成这一点的人是法官、警察局长、知识分子，我的意思是大学学生，来自，你知道的，成功人士，他们并不全是——刻板印象是说，哦，这些是愤怒的、被甩在后面的、怨恨的人，当然他们是，但他们中很多人都是非常适应良好、
high-minded people i think i mean i think what fascinated me about this subject was how moral ideals that had been instilled over centuries and centuries of Christian Europe could be trampled down so utterly. And it's the idea that there is no inherent human dignity, that all there is are rival races in a carnivorous struggle for dominance, that humans are nothing more than rival bands of chimps killing one another, and that that is the true stake that faces a people, a race, the defense of the bloodline. And the other is the idea that not only should you not care for the weak, but you should eliminate them. And I think that in both cases, I think it would be hard to imagine the Nazis doing what they did without the intellectual turbulence that followed Darwin. I'm not blaming Darwin for Hitler, but I think that that idea that nature is all about competition and that the strong should properly prevail over the weak,
思想高尚的人，我想。我的意思是，我认为这个主题令我着迷的是，几个世纪以来克里斯琴欧洲灌输的道德理想怎么能被如此彻底地践踏。这就是那种认为不存在内在的人类尊严，所有的只是肉食性争夺统治地位中的竞争种族，人类不过是互相杀戮的争夺地盘的黑猩猩群，这才是摆在一个民族、一个种族面前的真正利害关系，即血统的防线。另一个是不仅不应该关心弱者，还应该消灭他们。我认为在这两种情况下，我想很难想象纳粹会做他们所做的事，如果没有达尔文之后的知识动荡的话。我不是在责怪达尔文创造了希特勒，但我认为自然完全关乎竞争以及强者理应战胜弱者的那种想法，
which is a bastardized understanding of what Darwinism meant. I cannot imagine it happening in the way that it did. Because what is different between the Nazis and say the communists or the French revolutionaries is that the communists are upholding the idea that there is a kind of dignity in being at the bottom of the pile. I mean, that's what it's all about. Whereas the Nazis are not saying that. And also the communists are also, of course, very much internationalists. The counter arguments to that, Tom, would be that both Nazis and communists are equally keen on exterminating large numbers of people who don't fit the plan. Right. But the question is, for us, the quintessence
这是对达尔文主义含义的一种歪曲理解。我无法想象它会以那种方式发生。因为纳粹和共产主义者或法国革命者之间的区别在于，共产主义者坚持认为处于社会底层具有某种尊严。我的意思是，这就是它的全部意义所在。而纳粹并没有这样说。而且共产主义者当然也是坚定的国际主义者。对此的反驳，汤姆，会是纳粹和共产主义者同样热衷于消灭大量不符合计划的人。对。但问题是，对我们来说，邪恶的精髓
of evil is fascism, is Nazism, not communism. Even though Stalin killed and Mao between them killed far more than the Nazis did, Hitler remains for us the quintessence of evil because of the motives that he has in doing his killing. He's killing as a racist. He's not killing as someone who believes in a worker's paradise. So you think people are prepared to give some slack, as it were? at the bottom of the pile are endowed with a kind of a dignity and a power and a control is seen as being morally superior to the idea of wiping people out because of racist reasons, overtly racist reasons. I think you're probably right that people do think that though, of course, that's a terrible moral trap of its own, isn't it? Because it leads people to make excuses, as so many people, intellectuals did in the 1930s, for the most horrendous... Yeah, it is. But I think it's a reflection of the moral
是法西斯主义，是纳粹主义，而不是共产主义。尽管斯大林和毛泽东之间的杀戮比纳粹还要多得多，但希特勒对我们来说仍然是邪恶的精髓，因为他进行杀戮的动机。他是作为一个种族主义者在杀戮。他不是作为一个相信工人天堂的人在杀戮。所以你认为人们准备做出一些让步，可以说是吗？处在社会底层被赋予某种尊严、权力和控制力，被认为在道德上优于因为种族原因、公开的种族原因而消灭人们的想法。我想你可能是对的，人们确实这么认为，当然，这也是一个可怕的道德陷阱，不是吗？因为它导致人们为最可怕的事情找借口，正如20世纪30年代的许多知识分子所做的那样……是的，确实如此。但我认为这反映了长期统治欧洲的道德
assumptions that have governed Europe for as long as they have done, which is in turn why the Nazis serve as the ultimate political parable, political warning. We're far more nervous of Nazis coming to power, even the communists coming to power, even though both Nazis and communists have shown themselves utterly murderous when they do get totalitarian control. Because the nihilism is so offensive to our moral sense. I mean, to me, the Nazis, I think, are the Nazis a product of the late 19th century? I mean, clearly the ideas do come from the late 19th century, but it doesn't make it inevitable. So I think there's a future in which those ideas do float around, but they remain on the fringe or they percolate into mainstream politics. But to me, I mean, historians have different,
假设，这反过来也就是为什么纳粹成为终极政治寓言、政治警告的原因。我们对纳粹掌权的恐惧远甚于共产党人掌权，尽管纳粹和共产党人在获得极权控制时都表现得极其嗜杀。因为这种虚无主义太冒犯我们的道德感了。我的意思是，对我来说，纳粹，我认为纳粹是19世纪末的产物吗？我的意思是，很明显这些想法确实来自19世纪末，但这并不意味着它是不可避免的。所以我认为未来这些想法确实会四处流传，但它们仍然处于边缘地位或渗透到主流政治中。但对我来说，我的意思是，历史学家的看法不同，
some historians think the Great Depression is really the key thing. But for me, I just feel like the First World War is absolutely, the First World War doesn't make Nazism inevitable. It definitely means that there's going to be a i would say a dictatorship in germany at some point because there's a dictatorship in so many countries gone the great the great depression is so lethal for germany because of the first world war because they fought it because they have um got in debt over it because their economy has been destroyed by it it It's that that makes them
有些历史学家认为大萧条才是真正关键的事情。但对我说来，我只觉得第一次世界大战绝对是，一战并没有让纳粹主义成为不可避免。它绝对意味着德国在某个时候会出现一个独裁统治，因为有那么多国家都出现了独裁统治。大萧条对德国如此致命，是因为第一次世界大战，因为他们参与了战争，因为他们因此背负了债务，因为他们的经济因此被摧毁。正是这一点使他们
vulnerable. I mean, everything that afflicts the German state in the wake of the First World War is basically because of the First World War. Yeah, I think that's absolutely right. So if you compare something like Nazism, I would say so many of the conditions also existed. They were different, of course, maybe some of them less intense, but they existed elsewhere. So they might have existed. I mean, it pains me to say it, but you could imagine Britain losing the First World War and some terrible turn to a kind of resentful, bitter politics that involved perhaps scapegoating, who knows, the Irish, you know? Well, because that Darwinian, I shouldn't say Darwinian, the kind of social Darwinian habit of saying that, well, if you are strong, then you basically have the right to crush the weak.
变得脆弱。我的意思是，一战后困扰德国国家的一切基本上都是因为第一次世界大战。是的，我认为这绝对是正确的。所以如果你把像纳粹主义这样的东西进行比较，我会说很多条件也是存在的。当然它们是不同的，也许有些没有那么强烈，但它们在其他地方也存在。所以它们本可能存在。我的意思是，说这话让我感到痛苦，但你可以想象英国输掉了第一次世界大战，并以某种可怕的方式转向了一种怨恨的、痛苦的政治，这种政治可能涉及找替罪羊，谁知道呢，比如爱尔兰人，你知道吗？嗯，因为那种达尔文主义的——我不应该说达尔文主义，那种社会达尔文主义的习惯，即认为，好吧，如果你很强大，那么你基本上就有权粉碎弱者。
I mean, that's been manifest in British and French imperial policy, you know, out in the empire. Yeah, I think that's true. And that cast of, I mean, you know, out in the empire. Yeah, I think that's true. And that cast of, I mean, you know, it's often said that what the First World War does is to bring to the metropole, to Europe. The violence of the colonies. The violence of the colonies.
我的意思是，这在英国和法国的帝国政策中已经表现得很明显了，你知道的，在海外帝国中。是的，我认为那是真的。而且那种气质，我的意思是，你知道的，在海外帝国中。是的，我认为那是真的。而且那种气质，我的意思是，你知道的，人们常说一战所做的是把帝国边缘的暴力，带回了本土，带回了欧洲。帝国的暴力。帝国的暴力。
Yeah. Which is then what the Nazis go on to do is, you know, I mean, you know, concentration camps, the idea of the concentration camp is originally a British idea in the Boer War. Yes, and I think if you change the focus to France, I mean, France, you think of the virulence of the anti-Semitism in the read up to the First World War, the Dreyfus case. I mean, actually, you could tell this story about France and you could say, you know, democratic traditions, very imperiled. They'd had coups. They'd had Louiss they'd had louis napoleon
是的。这也就是纳粹后来所做的事情，你知道的，我的意思是，你知道的，集中营，集中营的概念最初是布尔战争中的一个英国主意。是的，如果把焦点转向法国，我的意思是，法国，想想一战前夕反犹太主义的恶毒程度，德雷福斯事件。我的意思是，实际上，你可以讲述这个关于法国的故事，你可以说，你知道的，民主传统，非常岌岌可危。他们经历过政变。他们经历过路易们，他们经历过路易·拿破仑
becoming napoleon the third there was a terrible sense of bitterness because of their opinion yeah in the franco-prussian war or dgs going back to napoleon um you know you could write a sort of alternative universe a french sonderveg story in which there's a french fascism that is exterminatory in the 1920s and 1930s i don't believe there was anything in the German character or the German culture necessarily. I think it's in Germany's experience, the shattering experience of the 1910s that then leads into the 1920s. And then, as we've discussed, a series of terrible, terrible decisions by people who had choices, who could have decided differently.
成为拿破仑三世，由于他们在普法战争中的观点，或者德雷福斯事件可以追溯到拿破仑，有一种可怕的痛苦感，你知道的，你可以写一个法国“特殊道路”故事的平行宇宙版本，其中在20世纪20年代和30年代存在一种具有灭绝性质的法国法西斯主义。我不认为德国人的性格或德国文化中必然存在什么东西。我认为它在于德国的经验，1910年代粉碎性的经验，然后通向1920年代。然后，正如我们所讨论的，一系列本可以做出不同决定的、有选择权的人做出的可怕的、可怕的决定。
You know, Hindenburg could have refused to let the Nazis into government, but they don't. And we know what happened next. Yeah. So I would say the swirl of ideas that then gets weaponized by the calamity of the First World War. And then, as you say, a series of contingent stages that could have gone other ways. And in that light, it could, again, it could have been France, it could have been Britain had they lost. Thinking back to Richard Evans and Ian Kershaw, they both say, okay, what's the future where those contingencies do go the other ways? And they say, probably Germany was going to have a military dictatorship in the 1930s, as most countries in Central and Eastern Europe did. So not dissimilar,
你知道的，兴登堡本可以拒绝让纳粹进入政府，但他们没有。我们知道接下来发生了什么。所以我可以说，在第一次世界大战的灾难中被武器化的各种思想漩涡。然后，正如你所说，一系列偶然的阶段本来可以走向其他方向。从这个角度来看，它本可以，再次强调，本可以是法国，如果他们输了本可以是英国。回想理查德·埃文斯和伊恩·克肖，他们都说，好吧，那些偶然性走向其他方向的未来会是怎样的？他们说，可能德国在20世纪30年代会有一个军事独裁政权，就像中欧和东欧的大多数国家一样。所以并没有什么不同，
and maybe would have fought wars, perhaps would even have been dragged into a war with the old allies of Britain and France. But the difference is no other regime would have so cold-bloodedly set out to murder 6 million Jews. I think that's the big difference. And that anti-Semitism was so crucial, so central to Nazism from the very beginning. One other factor, of course, is the Bolshevik Revolution, which is also, I think, a key factor, because that essentially means that there can be no kind of left-right alliance against the extremes. Yeah, I think you're absolutely right about that, Tom. I think it means that for a lot of sort of respectable middle-class Germans, any left-wing politics seems like a step down to this abyss that will end
也许会打仗，甚至可能被拖入与英国和法国老盟友的战争中。但不同之处在于，没有其他政权会如此冷血地着手谋杀600万犹太人。我认为这是最大的不同。这种反犹太主义从一开始就是如此至关重要，如此核心于纳粹主义。另一个因素当然是布尔什维克革命，我认为这也是一个关键因素，因为这基本上意味着不可能存在某种反对极端的左翼-右翼联盟。是的，汤姆，我认为你在这点上绝对是正确的。我认为这意味着对许多体面的中产阶级德国人来说，任何左翼政治都像是通向深渊的一步，最终会导致
in their property being taken away and them being shot as kulaks or something. You know, this terror of Bolshevism. Bolsheviks were never Hitler's primary target. The primary target was always Jews. But the fear of Bolshevism and of left-wing subversion and of revolution definitely drives people into his embrace. I think people who, again, should have known better, the teachers and priests and civil servants. Well, but we do know better now. I mean, again, that's the thing, isn't it? We do know better now. But I suppose then they didn't, because there hadn't been a Nazi regime.
他们的财产被剥夺，作为富农或类似的人被枪杀。你知道，对布尔什维克的这种恐惧。布尔什维克从来都不是希特勒的主要目标。主要目标始终是犹太人。但对布尔什维克主义、左翼颠覆和革命的恐惧确实将人们推入了她的怀抱。我认为那些本应该更明智的人，教师、牧师和公务员。好吧，但我们现在更明智了。我的意思是，再说一次，就是这样，不是吗？我们现在更明智了。但我想当时他们并不明智，因为以前没有过纳粹政权。
So Tom, last question, and a really, really cheery question for the new year. Do you think it could happen again? No, not like that. Oh, you surprised me. Because we have the example before us. There could absolutely be a collapse of implosion of democracy in a Western country. There could absolutely be an attempt to establish a totalitarian regime, but it would be very different. It would be, I think, subtler. The whole thing about the Nazis was that they were in your face. I mean, literally punching you in the face often. I think it would be, in a Western country, it would be subtler than that. And I think we will not have a reprise of,
所以汤姆，最后一个问题，也是一个为新年准备的非常非常欢快的问题。你认为它会再次发生吗？不，不会那样的。哦，你让我大吃一惊。因为我们有先例在眼前。西方国家绝对有可能发生民主的崩溃或内爆。绝对有可能试图建立一个极权政权，但它会截然不同。我认为它会更微妙。纳粹的全部特点是他们直面你。我的意思是，字面意思上经常是直接给你一拳。我想在一个西方国家，它会比那更微妙。而且我认为我们不会重演
of fascism because we have that example before us. It will be a different form of totalitarianism. I would say, and I hope that I don't live to be proved wrong, obviously. What do you think? I think there are obvious parallels of what happened in Russia in the 1990s with the Weimar Republic,
法西斯主义，因为我们有前车之鉴。它将是另一种形式的极权主义。我想说，我希望我不会活到被证明是错的那一天，显然如此。你怎么看？我认为90年代俄罗斯发生的事情与魏玛共和国有明显的相似之处，
the sense of humiliation, sense of economic, social, cultural collapse, um, the thirst for, for leadership, um,
那种屈辱感、经济、社会、文化崩溃感，对领导力的渴望，
the search for scapegoats, all of those things. I mean, it's not quite analogous. There's no exterminatory logic to, to Putinism. I mean, it's pure nationalism,
寻找替罪羊，所有这些事情。我的意思是，这并不完全相似。普京主义没有灭绝的逻辑，我的意思是，这纯粹是民族主义，
I suppose you would say. Even there, they're saying uh we're in a fight against nazis yeah they are you're right i mean i suppose remain so perhaps uh the only way that anything approximating to a nazi regime might come to power is by claiming to be fighting against nazis right yeah but maybe you could argue that our fixation on Nazis, I mean, there are lots of... So when Donald Trump was elected in 2016, there was a great vogue among sort of left-leaning Americans writing books and articles saying, you know, Trump is Hitler. This is how Nazi Germany started, all this. Well, Timothy Snyder did, didn't he? Yes. I mean, very, very great scholar with a huge un you know i mean incredibly detailed
我想你会这么说。即便如此，他们还是在说，我们在与纳粹作斗争，是的，他们是的，你是对的，我的意思是，我想仍然如此，所以也许，唯一可能接近纳粹政权的东西掌权的方式是声称在与纳粹作斗争，对，是的，但也许你可以争论我们对纳粹的执念，我的意思是，有很多……所以当唐纳德·特朗普在2016年当选时，在美国倾向左翼的作家和文章中有一种巨大的风潮，他们说，你知道，特朗普就是希特勒。这就是纳粹德国开始的方式，所有这些。嗯，蒂姆·斯奈德确实这么做了，不是吗？是的。我的意思是，非常非常伟大的学者，有着巨大的，你懂得，我的意思是，对这个主题有着令人难以置信的详细
knowledge of the subject yeah i mean timothy snyder does this writes this column you know three times a week i think or certainly did write it three times a week but i think the danger with that is that you're replaying the battles of the past on you that the threats to democracy in the future will be different they won't be they won't get their origin from the fevered sort of fringes of the 1890s or whatever. But also, I mean, America has its own pathologies that might lead to... Of course. Yeah. Each country has its own. I mean, that's the story of the Nazis. Every country's pathologies are slightly different. And the Nazis were unique to germany and no other
了解，是的，我的意思是蒂姆·斯奈德做了这个，每周写这篇专栏，你知道的，三次，我想或者肯定每周写三次，但我认为其中的危险在于你正在重演过去的战斗，未来对民主的威胁将是不同的，它们不会，它们的起源不会来自1890年代狂热的边缘群体什么的。而且，我的意思是，美国有它自己的病态，可能会导致……当然。是的。每个国家都有它自己的。我的意思是，这就是纳粹的故事。每个国家的病态都略有不同。纳粹对德国来说是独一无二的，没有其他
country could have produced a national socialist party looking just like that but i think any country could produce is capable of producing a similar kind of well because because i suppose if you know if we're saying it's specifically a fascist i mean for me the essence of fascism is the fusion of the futuristic with the with the antique yeah um so it would have to be national it would have to be nationalist and so it would have to draw on specifics within a country's historical tradition so there you go um anyway a cheery a cheery subject so we've had Auschwitz and we've had the rise of the Nazis in the first month of 2023. Things will cheer up, we promise. Yes, because on Monday we will be returning with Atlantis.
国家能够产生一个看起来完全一样的国家社会主义政党，但我认为任何国家都可以产生，有能力产生类似的一种，嗯，因为因为我想如果我们说这具体是法西斯主义，对我来说法西斯主义的本质是将未来主义与古代主义融合在一起，是的，所以它必须是民族主义的，它必须是民族主义的，因此它必须借鉴一个国家历史传统中的具体细节，所以你看，无论如何，一个欢快的主题，所以在2023年的第一个月，我们有了奥斯威辛，我们有了纳粹的崛起。情况会好起来的，我们保证。是的，因为周一我们将带着亚特兰蒂斯回归。
So a very different subject. Civilization plunging into the depths of the ocean. And to come we have subjects such as Christopher Columbus, the fall of the Aztecs, the Cathars, and the life and career of Ronald Reagan. And upstairs and downstairs.
所以这是一个截然不同的主题。文明陷入海洋深处。接下来我们还有诸如克里斯托弗·哥伦布、阿兹特克人的灭亡、卡特尔派以及罗纳德·里根的生平和职业生涯等主题。还有楼上楼下。
Oh yes, servants. In Edwardian Britain. The real Downton Abbey. So lots of slightly jollier subjects to come. So we'll say goodbye to you all and hopefully we'll see you next time. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye.
哦，是的，仆人。爱德华时代的英国。真正的唐顿庄园。所以还有很多稍微愉快一点的主题。所以我们要跟大家说再见了，希望我们下次再见。拜拜。拜拜。拜拜。
Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip.
感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。如需收听奖励剧集、提前收听、无广告收听并加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。那是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的其余部分》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦的好去处。
And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开了娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、奖励剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com 本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可发表评论。